so leute moin für frühe stunden heute für montag schweiß
wir probieren heute mal ein bisschen was aus mit einem label drucker den ich mir gekauft
habe müssen wir mal gucken inwieweit das unterlinungs funktioniert ich habe heute mal ausnahmsweise
wirklich gar nichts mit dem vorfeld angeguckt wir probieren das aus hier steht er noch mehr
oder weniger original verpackt und nicht angeschlossen der raspberry pi steht neben dran wir testen das
mal aus das ist der dm drucker ja also das mit dem dm habe ich erst gelesen nachdem ich den kram
schon bestellt habe und eigentlich wollte ich den wieder zurückschicken aber nachdem ich nicht so
viele labels drucker und ich mir mal angucken will bevor ich zurück schicke dann habe ich ja
nicht so viel zeit das ist der dm drucker sieht aus wie eine psp was das also ganz schön ganz
schön fette psp oder übrigens ist es es könnte sein dass ich mich spiegel heute monka es wo bleak
von oben
ein windows mein psp wie sah eine psp noch mal aus ich erkenne keine ähnlichkeit gar nicht
lull ach die rückseite da ein an wollen ich brain installieren
wenn ich pech habe es heute face reveal ja
wie war ich so viel javascript gedürfen sind sie in monka ist also was ich mir gekauft habe
ist folgendes zeige euch das ich habe mir ein dm label writer nicht laben alter nicht gaben
demo ich kann nicht schreiben leute demo label writer 450 gekauft bei amazon ein hochleistungs
beschriftungsgerät nicht irgendwie ein beschriftungsgerät ein hochleistungs was auch immer das was daran
die hohe leistung sein soll keiner kein schimmer so und eigentlich dachte ich dass es ein wifi
gerät ich habe nämlich bei amazon dm label wifi gesucht und wenn du bei amazon was auf
dm label wifi suchst dann ist das erste was du findest nicht den wirklich nicht der hat
auch kein der hat auch kein wifi im endeffekt ja das ist ich habe ich dachte mir weil ich
nach wifi gesucht habe bekomme ich auch wifi aber das ist nicht so war sie richtig massiv
so und jetzt habe ich einen drucker ohne wifi natürlich möchte ich den wifi p ich machen
und nach möglichkeit möchte ich auch nicht die offizielle app benutzen weil guckt euch
das mal an demo app ios wenn ihr mal wenn ihr mal eine der schlecht bewerteten apps überhaupt
sehen wollt guckt euch das an also die app ist wirklich absoluter bodensatz ich habe
noch nie gesehen dass man es schafft ein app mit 1,3 zu 1,5 ich wusste gar nicht dass
es wirklich ist ehrlich gesagt also meine app würde also wenn ich eine app releasen
würde der einzig die einzige chance dass das 1,3 bekommt ist wenn ich weeps out oder
so da reinschreibe dann weil sich dann die weil sich dann die ganzen die ganzen anime
fans angegriffen fühlen dann bekomme ich 1,3 würde ich weeps in schreiben dann hätte
ich 5 sterne aber die machen ja weder noch die app ist einfach kacke so deswegen was
ich nach möglichkeit gerne hätte ist einfach eine web anwendung mit der ich label drucken
kann ganz easy so und ich habe mir da auch schon was überlegt wir fangen heute nicht
an zu programmieren wir müssen erstmal testen so und was ich mir überlegt habe fife hat
heim warum schließe ich nicht also das ding ist usb gerät oder mal wo habe ich die kabel
also das ist ein usb das ist ein usb gerät was ich mir überlegt habe ich nehme einfach
den was ich labels drucken will zum beispiel zum beschriften von schubladen und kabel und
pin jumper kabel wo was hingeht ja zum beispiel sowas hier guck ich gebe dir header alter oder
hier oder hier sekunde ja oder hier sowas dass du weißt wo was ist dafür ist das eigentlich
ganz praktisch ja ich habe ja schon den label drucker also ich hatte die ganze zeit schon
ich hatte so ein demo sowas da sowas so ein ding hatte ich die ganze zeit schon das ist
auch ganz gut und reicht auch aus die sache ist plus die wenn du da ab dem zweiten label
fackt sich ab dass du da drauf rum tippen musst nachdem ich gerade am aufräumen bin
dachte ich mir so warum nicht mal ordentlich label drucker bestellen und mal schauen also
das ist das ding hier und da ist eine mini rolle dabei die mit mit dm so also und was
mir vorschwebt ist folgendes selbst mit als dann für den 19 monate massive subscription
so was ich mir überlegt habe ist folgendes was man machen könnte nachdem die mobile app
so kacke ist und ich auch kein bock auf die desktop app habe dachte ich mir man könnte
folgendes machen man macht sich eine web anwendung wo man dann trough embedded das bau wie gesagt
das programmieren wir heute nicht ich sage es euch nur mal ja ach ja guck mal das ist
wo ich das video aufgenommen habe hier kacke also wir könnten man kann könnte eine web
anwendung machen wo man trough embedded da kann man dann sein label drinne design und
dann exportiert man das als pdf oder als png und druck das auf dem drucker damit das
funktioniert brauche ich irgendwie einen treiber für dieses ding unter linux gibt es anscheinend
auch es müsste von der theorie hier relativ einfach sein das müssen aber ausprobieren
weil ihr wisst wie das ist wenn was in der theorie einfach aussieht heißt solange nicht
dass mögliche einfach ist heiterleiser danke für den sub das heißt von der theorie hier
muss ich kubbs installieren den dymodreiber für kubbs und dann kann ich über kommandoseile
text und pngs drucken so einfach kann man guck mal github dymodreiber ist doch etwas
komplizierter also wenn du dir hier den source mal anguckst
das was auch immer
das will man nicht wirklich unbedingt selbst machen alles hier
und außerdem ist es c++ ist auch egal die musik ist ein bisschen laut oder
das ist egal das ist ja kein kernel treiber das ist ein kubbz treiber kubbz kubbz treiber
kannst du wahrscheinlich auch in c++ machen
so also das schwebt mir so vor
und das wenn wenn ich heute alles hinkriegen ich werde als erst mal versuchen das ding
auf dem raspberry pi zu installieren und zu gucken ob ich einfach nur text drucken kann
achja das erste problem was ich habe ist schon mal ich weiß ich weiß gar nicht moment ich
mach mal kurz kurz ich weiß gar nicht wie man da wie man gescheit das überhaupt einsetzt
die patrone hat das jemand schon mal gemacht guck mal also das das habe ich ja schon gecheckt
hier das das habe ich das habe ich ja schon gecheckt dass man das hier so rein machen
muss dieses dieses label drucker ding ja das das habe ich ja schon gecheckt was ich nicht
gecheckt habe ist wie kriege ich das jetzt hier vorne dran hat das jemand schon mal gemacht
ich werde übrigens aus dem bild nicht wirklich schlau
keine ahnung wie das funktioniert man weiß das nicht es gibt da ja auch zig verschiedene
bänder ja ich habe keine ahnung wie das wie das funktioniert das müssen wir uns dann
gleich mal angucken ich muss ich muss das hier bestimmt bestimmt einmal durch mal egal
egal gucken wir mal erst mal muss ich das ding druck drucken können so also der plan
ist es irgendwie so einzurichten dass ich auf dem dass ich vom raspberry pi auf der
kommandoseile drucken kann und wenn ich den raspberry pi dazu überredet habe zu drucken
mal die anleitung raus anleitung nur noobs lesen anleitung so und wenn es dann geht dass
der unterlinux druckt dann kann ich eine web anwendung bauen die einfach png exportiert
und und an den drucker schickt so dazu müssen wir das ding erst mal ein raspberry pi anschließen
erst mal strom anmachen erst mal strom anmachen mal kurz kabel hier kabel weg ich lasse es
mal hier oben ihr seht ja da nicht viel ich mache jetzt den raspberry pi ich mache jetzt
strom an und dann schließen wir das ding schließen wir das ding mal an und dann loggen wir uns
auf dem raspberry pi ein und gucken ob das funktioniert aber das ding irgendwie dazu
überredet bekommen was auszudrucken probieren wir mal aus da ist ein usb kabel dabei richtig
schönes oldschool usb kabel und usb 2 kabel doch so richtig wie aus dem letzten jahrtausend
was das ding ja übrigens im prinzip auch ist ja wo ist denn hier usb wo ist denn überhaupt
der usb anschluss da ohne wahrscheinliche da moment es braucht usb sehe ich das richtig
das braucht usb und ein stromanschluss warum das denn oh man vielleicht geht es ja auch
so schauen wir mal so zack ich wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich geht das so nicht so und jetzt
verbinden wir uns mal auf den raspberry pi und schauen ist der das anscheinend uptime
ab seit null minuten ok das scheint der richtige raspberry pi zu sein keine ahnung übrigens
habt ihr gelesen dass es jetzt keine raspberry pi default user mehr gibt raspberry pi default
user sind weg seit der letzten raspian raspberry pi os version weil das irgendwie zu was mir
nicht zu security problematisch ist ein default user zu haben wo ich mir auch denke was ist
an einem default user security problematisch können auch nichts dafür wenn die leute den
kram nicht sein was dürfen die nicht mehr nach gesetzen dass ich zwar wieder komische
gesetze macht ist das der drucker mit den rfid papierrollen ja ja aber der hat keine
rfid papierrollen ich glaube das ist der led das ist der demo xl mit den mit den rfid mit
dem dm also man kann jetzt hier pie pie imager in der letzten version kann man hier oh ich
habe vergessen was man drücken muss schift i ne weiß jemand was man in diesem raspberry
piding für special option noch mal für eine tasten kombination drücken muss es gab
tasten kombination da konnte man jetzt die folgen password und so setzen habe ich vergessen
aus dem kopf wenn ich das nächste mal sehen dann also ich ändere das auch nicht ich ändere
auch nicht das password und sachen was ich mache ist ich kopiere mein ssh key und schalte
dann einfach password identifizierung ab fertig nicht password identifizierung password identifizierung
fertig was macht er da eigentlich für dinger wieder raspberry pie kernel hack alles klar
eckermanns sind wieder am start
ok da update jetzt eine weile ich dachte mir ich war mal schnell update dann rebooten wir
so ich habe übrigens auch eine anleitung dazu gefunden es gibt es gibt viele anleitungen
ja ich habe einfach mal gesucht dymokups dymokups wir accepten das risk kubstreiber installieren
genau was den dark wieder aus boah ne lass den dark wieder an aha newer kernel available
was zum was ja ich riebute ich riebute which service should be restart ja mach was du willst
mir egal ich muss das ding eh rebooten klein so reboot hat er jetzt eigentlich alles gemacht
voll upgrade komm gib ihm alles was geht reboot so und von der idee muss ich im prinzip nur
installieren die anleitung an sich brauchen wir gar nicht was die was der hier alles schreibt
die pakete sind ich muss cups und printer driver demo installieren soweit soweit die
theorie und dann sollte ich trocken können und es gibt auf github samples test label
mit irgendwo kommando zeilen beispiele genauso und danach sollte ich auf dem label drucker
so was hier ausdrucken können theoretisch die sache ist die text allein reicht mir nicht
ja habe ich schon mal verwendet vor 15 jahren oder so fanatics ich muss pngs ausdrucken
können ich muss also ich muss pngs ausdrucken können oder pdf und der muss das umwandeln
in das dym format handeln text alleine reicht nicht aber cups aber cups kann prinzipiell
guck hier gibt's png png kann man hier machen print image file lpr pp 300 page size bla
bla bla graphics da kann man test image ausdrucken ich muss ich muss ein richtig echtes png
ausdrucken können oder pdf damit ich trauer auch exportieren kann da bin ich mal gespannt
ich bin echt mal gespannt ob das funktioniert ok ssh geben wir mal auf den raspberry pi
darauf sudo jawoll gib ihm so also was was sagt er was ich installieren muss ich muss
erst mal gucken ob raspian überhaupt oder raspberry pi was überhaupt diesen dymotreiber
dabei hat ab wir machen mal update man weiß ja nie ich habe zwei upgraded aber immer mal
immer mal update vor vor install printer driver dymot ok das gibt's installiert der cups
als abhängigkeit mit nee macht er nicht alle installieren cups noch dabei ok halbe internet
wird nach installiert jetzt weißt du was das gute ist dass mein raspberry pi über
die ssd läuft da flutscht das wenigstens über die micro sd karte hätte jetzt wieder
ewig rum gerödelt hier seht ihr übrigens meinen ultra aufgeräumten basteltisch ordnung
in person hier wieder am start ich mein es passt zu meinem desktop oder ok so wir haben
es jetzt installiert so ok wie geht das mit dem drucken jetzt ok kups installiert printer
driver dymot installiert drucker einricht ok lp info minus fau er findet nix geil ab
ich habe den strom ja gar nicht dran den cups klein weiß ich ob ich den brauche ich habe
den strom am dymot gar nicht ranne sekunde moment netzteil dymot netzteil hier so ich
muss mal kurz entknoten gerade hier da dymot dymot stellts netzteil netzteil ich hab kein
stecker mehr frei leute guck mal das wird jetzt schwierig schaut mal wie machen wir
das jetzt kriege ich das da noch irgendwo rein das ist jetzt ziemlich blöd weil da
ist der raspberry pi dran da ist das switch dran und da ist das licht dran da das da
ich habe hier noch usb aber die usb sind ein bisschen zu bisschen zu lasch für den
raspberry pi ich mache den raspberry pi noch mal aus näh das licht brauchen wir das ist
ans kacke wir machen den raspberry pi aus glaubt mir das licht braucht man guckt man
erkennt es nicht richtig seht ihr oder reicht euch oder oder reicht euch das oder reicht
ja das reicht eigentlich oder reicht na gut wenn das reicht dann mache ich das licht
raus und den dymotrucker machen wir dann da rein so er leuchtet blau habt ihr gesehen
da guck mal kann man das drauf drücken oh er macht geräusche ich glaube er möchte
mir sagen ich habe es nicht richtig eingelegt so achtung und jetzt und jetzt warum ist das
da eingerissen überhaupt so einfach so aha aha aha ok ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich
das richtig gemacht habe leute ich habe kein blassen schimmer ob das stimmt ich meine
das label kommt da vorne raus wir schauen jetzt einfach mal ob das funktioniert so hast du
urlaub ich arbeite montags nie lp info da ist er guck mal direkt usb dymolabel writer
serial pochamp aha seriennummer league es muss so links bündig wie möglich sein ist
es guck mal guck mal guck mal also links bündiger naja wie kriege ich das wieder raus aha aha
moment moment moment aufrollen aufrollen nochmal mal aufrollen ich weiß halt nicht beim besten
wille nicht ob ich das richtig mache ach ach guck mal hier lull seht ihr das da kann
man so ein so ein führungs stell rein machen habe ich aber schon zu weit durchgemacht ok
ich glaube dem jetzt einfach mal dass es funktioniert so wie geht das jetzt weiter lp admin was
ich benutze kop so gut wie nie warum ist da noch plastik drauf ganz einfach dass ich
mich nicht spiegeln so jeweils eine ok dabei moment was jeweils eine für ein label der
tape drucke habe ich nicht ok das richtet den drucke anscheinend ein monka es kups alda
kups ist high iq das kann ich jeder spuk musiker ok kups kann ich jeder bedient sich sehe
ich jetzt schon was macht lp stat minus vor nix ok kups enable also ok das heißt ich mache
jetzt das da lp admin demo label minus usb dann kommt meine usb adresse hin und dann
user share kups man man alter wer hat sich das denn wieder ausgedacht das ist die die
hohe linux usability von der jeder spricht minus p das ist wahrscheinlich der drucker
user share kups model lw4 habe ich gar nicht kacquade user share kups model da ist nix
drin moment aber ich habe es doch ins ah moment das ist weiter die weiter die selbst runter
geladen hat ich habe ich habe ja printer driver demo installiert das liegt wahrscheinlich
woanders abt show content of package muss mal gucken wo er das wo er das hin installiert
hat dp kg minus l oder abt feil ok abt feil ist nicht installiert abt kann kann man so
machen dp kg minus l demo ok installiert
doch doch kups ist von apple mal irgendwann ok die anleitung ist pepega wir googeln mal
weiter kups filter driver für verschiedene demo etiketten drucker 450 ok
gibt es eine installationsanleitung irgendwie hau zu
linux kups du install du label weiter von 2007 ja meinetwegen hier printer driver
demo warum muss ich denn noch die treiber sachen von demo selbst runterladen was ist
denn das für ein sinnloses zeug warum warum brauche ich denn da jetzt beides postgres
sind doch nicht postgres post script sind auch dabei ich check es nicht ok was zum
das ist hrq shit ja warum warum gibt es aber ein package wenn die nicht dabei sind warum
gibt es printer driver demo und ich muss danach noch mal extra treiber runterladen das ist
doch schwachsinnig das ist doch bescheuert da muss man irgendwelche anleitungen suchen
wo das hau zu install das ist bestimmt ok das sind so eine fake china chinesen seite
alles in schwachsinn stinger warum brauche ich doch ein extra treiber wenn ihr die files
sind hier guck mal ich hab noch ins package geguckt da ist das nicht dabei also aus irgendwelchen
gründen was ist denn das ppd updaters ppd updaters driver updater das ist wieder unglaublich
und und durchsichtig alles ok demo kups linux da muss es noch mehr anleitungen reddit da
muss noch mehr anleitungen für geben sind die nicht einfach klaus ja aber die frage
ist was ist denn das hier was dabei ist ok ab zurtsch wie kann man sich die beschreibe
ok ob und wo wir suchen einfach mal die package beschreibung was der was der sagt was da
angeblich drinne ist was ist das aktuelle wenn das package nicht normalerweise eine
beschreibung hinter treiber vor demo label printers warum brauche ich dann extra noch
was ok ich hab kein plastenschimmer aber machen wir das mal ok download download kups treiber
also weget verbinden na geil na geil fängt ja gut an ok download demo linux kups demo
von 2006 oh ja das ist natürlich wahnsinnig geil das brauchen wir ja das da das will
ich haben ok da kann auch der download auch hobby link wie geht ab fack hoch 10 schaue
wieder ok machen wir haben was entpackt hier demo demo kups treibers oh wir haben sogar
eins vier null fünf krasser schitt auch das ist das ist schon angelegt ach jetzt kopiert
er das einfach rüber oder was jetzt das ist ja easy das ist ja easy also der kopiert sich
im prinzip den krempel von home vagrant was zum nein cp demo kups 45 model wie weit ich
habe noch nichts gedruckt ne ne so also was brauchen wir jetzt samples ne ppd ppd ach
da ist es guck mal label writer 450 450 dl 450 dt 450 450t 450tt und was ist der unterschied
dazwischen jetzt was was ist denn jetzt der unterschied zwischen den ganzen files ach
was das gefunden also ich habe den ganz normalen ich habe den da label writer 450 der liest
denn sowas alter also das ist dann das ist dann 450 duo 450 also ich habe den ganz normalen
450 wahrscheinlich ok 450 was hat der typ hier in der anleitung
lv 450 ach der macht es auch für duo ok ich habe den ganz normalen 450 ok ppd nach user
share kups model ok so und jetzt führen wir den krempel aus was printer try was adi
sprecated wie warum sind printer try but brauche man nicht mehr oder was it's overrated
wie jetzt ok ich will leute ich weiß was wir machen wir gucken jetzt wie wir den krempel
einrichten und wir bauen dann am ende irgendeinen dockercontainer draus wo es dann einfach immer
geht das ist kein nein das ist nicht der dm drucker glaube ich zumindest der dm drucker
ist dieser xl treiber sind plaud das braucht man alles nicht genau so das haben wir schon
gemacht oder lp start minus v device for demo ok so und jetzt und jetzt und jetzt was kups
kups enable demo kups except für was macht kups except ich verwende kups nie ich habe
keinen plan davon kups except reject jobs sent to destination ok kups except demo nicht dass
ich wüsste was ich jetzt mal guck mal echo dies ist ein test haha lp minus moment wir
machen das hier mit den beispielen daraus hier lpr minus o landscape test irgendwo hatte
ich doch so das beispiel irgendwo hatte ich sogar das beispiel mit pngs hier png da lpr
oder oder print textfile page size ich habe keine ahnung was ich für eine page size hab
wir sind das standardmäßig ok wir können es aber mit lp minus d testen wir machen das
jetzt übrigens richtig pro demo ist wahrscheinlich der drucker so und an der stelle setzen wir
eine namepipe ein echo hallo mal gucken ob das funktioniert wow hat er das jetzt gemacht
boah hat hallo gedruckt guck mal da porkchamp das ging ja mega schnell man habt ihr gesehen
wie das geflutscht ist das ding das das ist hat ja nahezu jep jep cock hat das gemacht
so ich mach das mal wieder rückgängig hier leute weil ich sehe es nicht ein meine teure
den teuren kram zu wasten noch mal testen leute raspberry pi ist ab warum ist der raspberry
pi abgekackt meine ssh session ist abgeschissen abzahlen warum ist meine ssh es ist einfach
die ssh session abgekackt jetzt guckt es euch an hallo zack bum funst so wir drucken mal
ein bisschen mehr ich mach das jetzt leute ich mach das jetzt so lang hierdurch ich lasse
es jetzt einfach auf ich lasse es jetzt einfach auf scheiß drauf so wir drucken mal ein bisschen
mehr echo minus e hallo cute chat backslash n blub backslash n blub backslash n boah das
geht ja das ist ja mal richtig das flutscht ja mal richtig seht ihr mal wie schnell das
ging drück man hier guck mal das steht nice so wie gesagt ich will nicht so viel bann
verschwenden da ist nicht so viel dabei zeig mal in groß ok in groß moment in groß sleep
in fünf sekunden druckt er jetzt achtung in groß da ich meine ich habe jetzt fünf
mal drüber gedruckt ja fast as fuck ja das ist ja ich habe jetzt nur fünf mal drüber
gedruckt weil ich die das band nicht warum blinkt er eigentlich so doof da vorne wahrscheinlich
weil er offen ist oder ist ihm egal er kehrt nicht selbstzerstörung initiated
so gut also da muss ich ja sagen das ging jetzt tatsächlich verhältnismäßig easy
was für bänder gibts denn da eigentlich alle dümo band ne na was muss ich da jetzt
suchen dümo label weiter 450 wie heißt was für bänder gibt es denn da alles dafür druck
bis zu 51 etiketten pro minute da gibt es auch bestimmt mehrere unterschiedliche bänder
oder adress etiketten groß hochleistungs etiketten da gibt die jetzt bestimmt in größer
und in kleiner und in mehrzweck etiketten zum beschriften von ähm theoretisch kann
ich den auch wunderbar zum beschriften von post verwenden das riecht poc aber eigentlich
will ich zum beschriften von schubladen von irgendwelchen kabeln wo irgendwas lang führt
und sowas in der richtung ich hab mir ich ganz ehrlich ich hab mir das ding ja eigentlich
nur bestellt weil ich dachte das ist wireless
ja da muss ich mal gucken was es dafür unterschiedliche etiketten gibt
das ist eine super idee dann ist das ding aber relativ schnell lehr abzocken rfid label
etiketten band was gibt es denn da für verschiedene etiketten bänder das steht doch das gibt
auch das steht auf stunden bei dümo auf der webseite oder beschriftungsgeräte etiketten
was es da alles gibt etiketten und schriftbänder ja ja except was gibt es denn da alles rege
bänder label writer etiketten original etiketten für label writer versandaufkleber original
etiketten für adressen gelb pink blau grün permanent haftend ok ich hätte gern welche
die nicht so lang sind ok es gibt 50.000 verschiedene dinger wieder
ok was auch immer das muss ich mir mal angucken was ich viel interessanter finde ist wie kann
ich hochkant wie kann ich denn hochkant drucken aktuell druckt er ja so das kann ich hier
bestimmt mit der passenden option machen so das nächste was wir tun müssen ist bilder
drucken bilder das wird jetzt schon ein bisschen schwieriger bilder drucken sind das sind
das pixel meint ihr meint ihr das sind pixel page size printing on continuous paper ein
unterschied dazwischen weil das so lang ist machen wir es mal damit ok
hallo cute chat wir machen wieder nur mal eine zeile 123 was lpr not found warum
nicht da muss lpr muss dafür kurz klein installieren search lpr youtube dl alles klar das brauche
ich brauche da kurz klein für dp k g minus l kurz kleint lp lpr ok wen installiere ich
lpr ubuntu lpr cups bsd was cups bsd bsd commands meinetwegen auch cups bsd ist mir
egal ok was das echo ich achja ich hab das echo vergessen tatsächlich aber es egal ging
trotzdem nicht ok no default destination man lpr printer name
ich verwende nie cups ich hab kein plan sleep ok lp minus d dymokie vielleicht auch hier
minus d minus d dymokie ich weiß auch hier drucke angeben muss wie macht man das minus
lpr specify printer minus p destination einfach vielleicht minus p dymokie hatte mich interessiert
lp mal gucken ob das normale noch funktioniert sleep oh er ist broken er geht nicht mehr
warum nicht was ist wo ist dein problem dymoman hey stop alter what the fuck dymoman hör auf
meine schönen labels meine labels das ist die drucke das ist die drucke jetzt abgeht
die schönen labels alle ok heute ich muss das nochmal rückhängen ich mach jetzt sofort
hier lass lass drucke lass mich das zurückziehen auf ja und wieder aufrollen wieder aufrollen
meine schönen labels so schon viel besser so ok 123 please
der denkt es ist drucker stau es ist kein stau man what the fuck alter dymoman was willst
du von mir moment leute moment moment mein was ist das hier was das für ein knopf was
das keine ahnung am anfang hat es auch funktioniert what the fuck was macht das was dymoman was
ist denn hier los ok ok leute ok wir müssen das anders machen da muss jetzt der strom erstmal
rausgezogen werden so kann man das aufklappen kann man das irgendwie aufklappen oder so
ich ich ich verschwende garantier nicht mein ganzes mein ganzes etikettending ist nicht
mehr linksbündig ja wahrscheinlich weil ich zu viel herumgezerrt habe soll ich mach das
jetzt erstmal kurz wir rollen das jetzt erstmal wieder auf wir rollen das jetzt erstmal wieder
auf so macht das mal ab gut wird das erstmal wieder wird das erstmal wieder aufgerollt
bräuchte mal bisschen platz zum hinlegen so guckt schön schön schön aufrollen alles
das hat jetzt gar nicht wie fünf euro gedruckt oder so keine ahnung guckt hat kann jemand
von euch mal gerade während ich hier aufrolle nachgucken wie teuer der krempel ist wie viel
kostet kostet das so kogas wie viel kostet kostet so etikettenband ok ich hab's wieder
aufgerollt 6 euro ok so linksbündig moment erstmal erstmal muss ich glaube ich reinstecken
jetzt linksbündig so ok ok jetzt mach ich mal wieder an ok gut ok das funktioniert ja
prinzipiell so und das hier funktioniert das jetzt auch das funktioniert prinzipiell
auch 123 das funktioniert prinzipiell auch so und jetzt versuche ich mal ich kann jetzt
eh noch 20 etiketten drucken weil der krempel ich hab mir eh schon versaut auf der rückseite
sind microcodes damit etiketten nicht mehrfach bedruckt werden es scheint ja trotzdem zu
funktionieren 4 cent alter das ist ja ganz schön teuer zum glück haben die dinger kein
drm zum glück haben die dinger kein drm beim label writer 400 humo kompatible etiketten
schauen wir mal ist ja gleich viel billiger hier guck mal kostet gleich nur die hälfte
bop bop brennt 18 euro 5 stück
label writer 54 kompatible ok 5 stück 4 stück ok das gibts das gibts doch schon das gibts
billiger da sieht man mal wie affig das ist tatsächlich drm drm einzubauen in seine etiketten
oder ach guck mal das sind kleinere seht ihr das das sind kleinere das sind 52 x 32 das
probieren wir jetzt auch mal aus schaut mal wenn ich jetzt sage page size keine ahnung
20 oder ne ne ne die breite kann ich ja gleich lassen breite und höhe nur 20 was macht
er dann juckt ihn nicht oder das juckt ihn glaub ich nicht was zum aufhören das juckt
ihn nicht oder der juckt immer das komplette etikett aus warum warum macht er immer das
komplette etikett warum juckt den page size nicht er er er er er doesn't care für die
page size so wir probieren mal ein bild das ist das eigentliche was ich ausprobieren will
landscape ok minus minus o was landscape hat er jetzt landscape gedruckt gar nix gedruckt
oder hat er jetzt landscape gedruckt ich seh da nix lululululul landscape ne der druck
gar nix wenn ich landscape mach na minus o muss man ja doppelt machen können oder jaja
es geht geht doppelt landscape was nicht label alignment right center was cut options
continuous paper macht er dann macht er dann hört er dann auf nachdem das ich hab keine
ahnung was ich hier mache eigentlich gerade mal ne das ist jetzt andere größe das juckt
den alles nicht dass das juckt das juckt jetzt ist dem komplett egal so also ich will jetzt
einmal ein bild probieren hier bild was pot was portrait das landscape warum ich mein
das offizielle doc sagt ich mein kann ich mal machen das ist dem egal das als bild ok
das ist schön klein das können wir als bild machen jepp jepp cock als bild copy address
das moment ffz jepp cock das brauchen wir anders wo gibts denn das bild braucht das
in größer ich brauch das in größer hier das da das da copy image link achso moment
wir brauchen das erstmal als ähm wir brauchen das als png wir brauchen das als png leute
wir brauchen das ich kugel doch nicht danach wir brauchen das als png ähm image convert
ja genau convert 3x ja jepp punkt png ich weiß nicht was ich für ein image viewer hab
jepp wine für den bild wine alles klar ja da ist es doch ok
jepp so pie jepp minus null png ne scp jepp minus null png da sind wir also ähm wo haben
wir hier png so minus p demo pppdings da ppega stellts 450 äh nein ähm äh pie nicht p
pie äh jepp oh gar nichtmal so schlecht oder gar nichtmal so schlecht ich mein das ist mit
komischer transparenz und es ist ein labeldrucker das geht doch eigentlich oder geht doch eigentlich
voll klar so aber jetzt probieren wir mal jetzt jetzt probieren wir mal was sinnvolles
jepp cock gmbh kassenzettel na jetzt jetzt probieren wir mal was sinnvolles was macht
der wenn du das gif rein steckst ich glaube der kann gar kein gif das muss cups cups muss
das können und ich glaube cups kann kein kein gif ich mein wir können es mal ausprobieren
was passiert wenn ich das gif da rein steck oder wo die coolen leute sagen dass das gif
probieren wir mal aus was was ist wenn ich das gif da rein stecke es wird nur der erste
frame muss man ausprobieren copy link v nach jepp.gif schauen wir mal jepp.gif der kann
das einfach guckt mal der druckt wirklich nur das erste das erste den ersten frame aus
so und jetzt jetzt müssen wir was ausprobieren na nicht affinitive foto das ist das falsche
designer quit also jetzt bauen wir mal testweise ein etikett und gucken wir mal ob wir das
gescheit gedruckt kriegen jaja ok remind me later later close new ähm was brauchen
wir 167 mal 233 nicht millimeter pixel null 167 mal was haben wir gesagt 288 kommt das
überhaupt hin leute kommt das hin sekunde wartet mal so na super jetzt die batterie leer
na geil also was haben wir denn hier so das ist chat wieviel oh ihr seht ja gar nichts
null wieviel wieviel haben wir wieviel haben wir das sind übrigens centimeter und nicht
inches 36 ja was irgendwie keinen sinn ergibt oder ach guck mal können wir bei der gelegenheit
mal was anderes ausprobieren 36 was haben wir hier mal ich würde sagen ungefähr 90
würde sagen ungefähr 90 ungefähr 90 millimeter also haben wir nicht noch also haben wir 90
ja 85 das recht 85 85 millimeter höhe dann haben wir gar nicht das da das sind ja moment
was ist denn das jetzt sind das sind das hier pixel oder millimeter was ist denn das ounces
ok dann suchen wir einfach mal ganz offiziell amazon demo etiketten wie groß die sind label
writer 450 was sind dafür etiketten dabei standardmäßig
was hier was sind das standardmäßig für etiketten
muss aber du mal wieder gucken was sind das was sind das wieder für etiketten
original etiketten für label writer ok sind die das kein schimmer ob die das sind
wir haben 85 wir haben 85 millimeter demo etiketten 85 89 89 mal
986 36 vielleicht ich habe nachgemessen 986 36 es könnte doch sein das könnte doch sein
guckt mal das werden die wahrscheinlich sein schaut mal wir haben naja also neun sind es
nicht aber wer weiß von wo die zählen sagen wir mal 89 und das hier sind 39 jahre kommt
auf der rückseite excellent auf der rückseite steht das da mal kurz gucken ob ich auf der
kamera besser erkennen das inches 36 mal 39 80 millimeter ja haben wir doch richtig haben
36 mal 89 das ist riesen das ist huge massive also millimeter also brauchen wir hier millimeter
millimeter reite 36 und höhe 100 89 oder oder wir machen es hochkant wir machen das
einfach so so und jetzt jetzt hier will ich mal ein label machen und gucken ob man das
als png gescheit gedruckt bekommt also sagen wir mal label text um habe ich das hier alles
text cute chat 123 impact schön fett massive design fps ja also hier unser unser unser
toller firmen name ist das jetzt brauchen wir noch ein logo pepo fett pepo fett als logo
pepo fett copy image bitte mit transparenz kopieren nicht einfach so pepo fett als logo
jawoll so sehr schön sehr schön excellent so und jetzt irgendwie noch was unten drunter
eben ein bisschen kleiner keine ahnung frankfurt am main cute street 69 so perfekt bestes label
überhaupt das will ich jetzt haben huge design ja finde ich auch export
ich muss das erst noch spiegeln oder
ich muss das ich muss das ich muss das erst noch nur wobei das so ach nee das ist dpi
haben wir ja nee nee das ist richtig ist richtig ok export ja was weiß ich desktop sehr schön
label ach so wie krieg ich das jetzt in meine vm kann man das gescheit tracken droppen label
sehr schön cp sehr gut scp label ok dann drücken wir das mal ppi ist ppi und dpi das
gleiche points per inch und dort und das andere dots per inch oder das gleiche wahrscheinlich
nicht das wäre sonst zu einfach label
ich sag es ja nur ungern aber das hat wirklich ganz gut funktioniert der hat pepo fett der
hat pepo fett zu fett gedruckt guck mal pepo fett hat noch aufs andere ticket rüber gedruckt
vielleicht ist unsere page size doch nicht so richtig was hatten wir moment wir hatten
breite ich hab schon wieder vergessen breite nee 36 89 hatten wir oder das interessiert
den überhaupt nicht das geht dem voll am arsch vorbei gatschi bass guck mal also das interessiert
den nicht so wirklich gut ich mein das wäre jetzt kein ding das könnte man alles ein bisschen
nach oben schieben aber ok ja leute wir machen jetzt noch mal eine sache wir machen den noch
mal machen den noch mal aus wir machen den auch noch mal auf wir machen den noch mal
raus und ich roll das ganze noch mal auf weil ich sehe es nicht ein meine ganzen leibels
für dieses geteste hier raus was ist denn das da eigentlich für einen knopf leute
was das für ein knopf das muss ich mir jetzt erstmal angucken wie viel besser ist da findet
die designer gegenüber inkscape ich hab keine ahnung ich hab inkscape nie verwendet label
writer 450 pdf du hast eine kaufmännische ausbildung also chat zeig mal kurz die dymodinger
fressen wohl auch no name label den ich habe gibt es irgendeinen kannst du einen zebra
etikettendruck empfehlen da standardmäßig schon wlan hat
und den guten treiber für linux hat wenn nicht wenn nicht wlan also oder irgendein
hey max ich habe eine kaufmännische ausbildung und bin seit 3,5 jahren quer einsteiger in
it hast du habt ihr gute tips was sich an weiterbildung lohnt um im bereich systemadministration
auch in zukunft berufliche chancen haben lp oder slp ist das lp ja also ganz ehrlich ich
persönlich gebe ja auf zertifizierung nicht sonderlich viel wichtig ist also wenn du es
kommt natürlich immer ein bisschen auf das unternehmen an aber ein bisschen richtung
cloud zu gucken ist als linux mann in der aktuellen zeit wirklich sinnvoll also sich
mit solchen sachen wie ansible terraform kubernetes zu beschäftigen dir mal aws anzugucken
azure anzugucken wie heißt der krempel von google normal google gcp heißt das glaube
ich der google krempel anzugucken du kannst dir mal digital außen angucken du kannst
ja auch die hetsner cloud angucken womit ich noch bis letztes jahr 21 euro startgutschein
bei mir sichern konnte aber hetsner bis jetzt noch kein bock hatte das zu verlängern ne
super hochpreis ich brauche ich nicht ich brauche nix für 500 euro nein also mir ist
ja gute qualität mir ist zwar gute qualität wichtig aber 310 ok es ist aber auch ganz
schön teuer ich meine ich habe 100 100 euro oder so für das demo ding als bezahlt ok nicht
ohne ja aber noch mal dazu also lp kann man was ich weiß falls das lp kann man machen
ich gebe da jetzt persönlich nicht so viel drauf wie gesagt auf jeden fall sich ein
bisschen im cloud umfeld umgucken und da auch ein bisschen rum probieren erfahrung ist
durch nichts zu ersetzen ja so ich muss jetzt aber erst mal kurz wieder aufrollen leute
also ich wollte jetzt ich wollte ins handbuch gucken was das für eine bedienungsanleitung
label printer ja was ist das für ein knopf ich brauche ein bild von den knöpfen genau
hier das da taste etiketten auswurf was macht das
der etiketten auswurf passiert nix ok label wo ist denn meiner 450 taste vorschub taste
und status anteil taste etiketten auswurf ok etiketten auswurf funktioniert bei mir
schon mal nicht alles klar ok wir rollen das jetzt mal was ist hier neben das etiketten
entriegelung etiketten zuführen abrissleiste usb anschluss jaja ja gut das ist nicht so
viel würde ich sagen hast du nicht ausgesteckt tatsächlich aber das will ich ja gar nicht
ich will jetzt das hier und wieder aufrollen das ganze ding also ich zeige euch jetzt noch
mal was er ausgedruckt hat zeige euch noch mal kurz was er ausgedruckt hat ist ja gar
nicht schlecht ja muss man ja muss man ihm erlassen ist ja gar nicht schlecht leider
druckter über den druckter ein bisschen falsch der fängt zu weit links an schaut mal ok
herr frankfurt passt nicht dafür der fängt hier an zu drucken ansonsten ist das doch
durchaus in ordnung kann man sich nicht beschweren so erstmal wieder aufrollen erstmal wieder
aufrollen weil ansonsten wird es teuer pepo fett pepo fett pepo fett als hätten die
komponisten dieser musik permanent sich im hinterkopf gedacht pepo fett jetzt wirds
cringe alter warum teuer weil das dm etiketten sind weil der hersteller sich denkt fid chips
in etiketten sind eine gute idee muss man kurz gucken ob meiner wirklich fids hat oder
nicht ok ich habe aufgerollt so komm her pepo fett
ok rein damit so also jemand noch eine glorreiche idee warum da zu früh anfängt zu drucken
alter warum bricht denn warum bricht denn war der geschlagenheit die ssh verbindung ab
zu meinem zu meinem raspberry pi ist doch total habe ich den raspberry pi aus versehen
ausgesteckt gerade monka s was jetzt
ok warum ist der raspberry pi denn jetzt im arsch
wenn jetzt los was naja gut ziehen wir den raspberry pi mal raus und machen neu an
schub falsch musst du ein offset angeben wie kompatible etiketten das sind die etiketten
mit dem das ding ausgeliefert wird also das muss ja schon funktionieren hast du das repo
dm uss service von adler web angeschaut ja das habe ich lustigerweise letztens auf youtube
gesehen das bringt mir nicht so viel das ist für
ihn so ein außer aus der reihe gedenksten microcontroller und der web service an sich
der gefällt mir nicht da kann was schöneres bauen aber erstmal muss das ding ordentlich
drucken ach guck mal da sind wir wieder liegt wohl an dem vier millimeter unterschied
muss man vielleicht wirklich das etikett kleiner machen
das können wir mal ausprobieren jetzt vielleicht vielleicht muss man die etikette vielleicht
muss man das kleiner machen also page size pimo page size was haben wir da
ja ja ich muss so gucken was ich da angeben muss also wir haben wir hatten doch jetzt
36 89 36 89 ich finde nichts mehr ansatzweise in dieser in dieser richtung 54 41 36 98 ist
da nix default page size 81 ok 81 ok 81 aber das ist die breite
eh
amin ist vielleicht hier irgendwie im treiber drin stehen was ist was die was die size sind
die ich verwenden kann ppd lm 450 page size hier 35
es gibt hier angeblich nix das ist der label manager ich habe den label writer habe ich
auch das richtige kopiert vorhin user share user share hoops model label writer habe ich
habe es richtig gekopiert ok page size also was haben wir hier schönes zu bieten also
wir brauchen irgendwas mit 30 vorne und 89 boah alter gibt es da viel 36 das ergibt keinen
sinn das ist überhaupt nicht ja was muss ich denn als für eine größe angucken 36 ja
geil oder ha 36 36 es gibt nur 36 106 pepega kram alter was soll ich da vergleichen da
steht 36 mal 89 oder sind das inche inches ok moment moment mein ami shit ist das jetzt
in inches oder ist das in zentimetern oder in millimetern
36 9 millimetern das sind millimetern das sind millimetern aber ist die page size ok
moment 36 mm to inches was ist denn sagt mal leute was ist was ist die zu zoll was ist denn
die millimeterequivalent von von inches was ist die kleinere einheit von zoll mini zoll
oder alter ami einheiten mann
freedom alter freedom hell yeah inches haben wir es auch in millimeter vielleicht boah mann
1,4 14 das darf vielleicht 14 ich habe nicht kein blassen schimmer was die mir damit sagen
wollen alter page size mann kokona shit
also ich muss jetzt da war oben die erklärung was ok wo ist deine erklärung ich sehe da
keine iso latin warm das ist auch mal wieder irgendwas übrig gebliebenes inches page size
fall page size ich bin ja fast dafür wir machen try an error wie groß die sind 36 mal 89 naja
wurscht
ich weiß was wir machen wir gehen auf amazon kommen
es gibt keine verpackung vom band ich weiß was wir machen moment wir suchen uns raus
und da steht irgendeine nummer dabei
modellnummer
so und das und das vergleichen wir jetzt das sind points nicht millimeter
das steht da auch das steht da auch in millimeter vorne drauf steht das auf der deutschen packung
der kann dann in solchen einheiten rechnen man ein vierzehntel in dreimal ein halb inch
was was wie hat sich das denn ausgedacht wieder mann
ach du kacke jetzt hast du deine size näher ich weiß nicht wirklich welches also es hat
mich jetzt nicht das hat mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich weitergebracht um ehrlich
zu sein
page size das hat mich jetzt nicht wirklich weitergebracht wenn ich ehrlich bin was was
mache ich was macht er eigentlich bringt moment bringt diese page size überhaupt was lpr lpr
so page size ich lasse die page size jetzt einfach mal weg
wtf der druckt jetzt sonst wohin ok vielleicht war es nicht richtig
jetzt wieder das gleiche druckt wieder er druckt wieder auf der anderen side so wir testen ob
diese page size irgendwas macht page size ich gebe dir jetzt mal was total
bescheuertes an 500 mal 500 ich habe keine ahnung was das macht aber gucken wir mal
das ändert mal absolut gar nichts die page size interessiert dir nicht ok dann ist es
rein eine sache wie mein bild gemacht ist wahrscheinlich so das heißt ich muss mein
bild anders machen also jetzt habe ich weil es kann sein dass sie mal png nicht interessiert
edit wie ging das auf preferences ich mache nie nachträglich nachträglich die bildgröße
document document etc ok 36 millimeter sag mal leute soll das doch rotieren das bild
auf der anderen seite auf der anderen seite es hat ja funktioniert es hat ja funktioniert
nee ich muss es nicht rotieren das hat ja prinzipiell funktioniert da scheint es da
scheint es ja selbst schon zu rotieren kein kogas rotieren include margins tja das müssen
wir jetzt rausfinden was man da wie drucken kann dümo png cups dreht das mal um 180 grad
naja es stimmt ja alles außer dass es das das an der stelle abschneidet also ein bild
ist weiter draußen wie meine adresse ja und er druckt ja beides nicht der schneidet ja
beides ab außerdem muss das funktionieren das ist ja alles auf den richtigen dimensionen
ja ich meine wir können das wir können das mal rezaille können mal gucken was dann passiert
wenn wir testen selbst einfach mal ein bisschen ran also ich meine nach oben und unten ist
ja durchaus in ordnung das passt ja wobei nach unten leute guckt mal wartet mal man
muss da bestimmt einfach ein bisschen was weglassen kann das sein dass sie das komplette
messen hier dass sie dieses die komplette size messen ja guck mal die messen das komplette
das ist 39 hier das hier ist 39 das etikett selber ich habe leider keine batterie mehr
drin das etikett selber ist weniger so und jetzt machen wir das noch mal kurz hier auch
das gesamte ist das ist eher 89 hier also du musst auf jeden fall ein bisschen abziehen
das müsste jetzt müsste man wissen wie groß ist die etikettfläche von diesem ding
na der eine millimeter wird es wahrscheinlich nicht machen also wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
brauche ich 85 oder sowas ja 85 und nach oben ja keine ahnung meinst du oben zwei millimeter
da unten zwei millimeter oder sowas und unten und da machen wir und oben und unten 32 85
82 ob das jetzt besser funktioniert export label 2 ach so was sagt er denn wie groß
ins pixel ist ja ist ein bisschen anders ok dann schieben wir es mal rüber wir machen
jetzt mal was anderes dass ich das einfacher rüber kopiert kriege es das ssh fs haben
wir hier aber ich habe sogar ssh fs ssh fs wo wir mounten uns den raspberry pi drüben
was ich damit label will schubladen kabel alles mögliche zeug vielleicht auch mal als
eine andere adress aufkleber also jetzt kopieren wir das rüber label 2 scp nach ssh fs zack
und jetzt haben wir hier irgendwo wenn ich es richtig gemacht habe haben wir als ein
label 2 soll mal schauen ob das jetzt besser ist nö naja doch doch leute seht ihr das
guckt mal das ist besser das ist deutlich besser schon schaut mal das ist deutlich besser
seht ihr das also hier hat er frankfurt gemacht bis sonst was und hier hat er frankfurt gemacht
es ist fast alles drauf seht ihr das ich habe die hand label maschine ja ja habe ich also
dann machen wir das noch mal anders document setup ja aber man muss das doch irgendwie
ausrechnen können ich kann doch jetzt nicht auf gut glück den den krempel den krempel
da machen also dimensions ich würde sagen wir machen einfach nochmal 2 cm 2 cm wir machen
komm wir machen wir machen es auf wir machen es auf eine gerade zahl wir machen 82 draus
und 80 millimeter 80 mal 36 warum also man muss es doch irgendwo nachgucken können muss
es doch irgendwo nachgucken können was man was man wirklich braucht du mo etiketten millimeter
rand soll man nach rand gucken 36 waren auch ein bisschen offset oder sowas du mo label
offset
was ist das hier du mo millimeter label in portrait orientation printed images shifted
down man hat das gleiche wie gleich wie bei mir der hat anscheinend rausgefunden was das
richtige ist ach guck mal page region gibts und page size und imageable area meine güte
warum ist dieser scheiß wieder so absolute wissenschaft für sich warum ist das immer
so wahnsinnig pepega gemacht alles und warum ist das da ist das die nummer moment du mo
das ist die nummer vom etikett das ist die nummer vom etikett jetzt jetzt haben wir es
leute das ist die nummer vom etikett das hier sind die what the fuck ah wie ist er gut krieg
dich ein man das ist die nummer vom etikett paper dimensions 102 mal 252 was genau hat
102 mal 252 mit 36 mal 89 zu tun das ist weder inches das ist punkt aber punkt in was von
wo nach wo wie komme ich von meinen millimeter in punkte mit 300 oder was also muss ich dann
89 durch 300 oder wie was was kommt dann eigentlich wenn ich ok 98 durch 300 200 nicht wirklich
millimeter 2 1 1 was ok was was bin ich sehend überhaupt warum sind 39 millimeter 252 punkte
warum also was ist das überhaupt ob wir jetzt leute obviously alles in stonks investieren
jetzt drucker zeug cringe leute das weiß man doch ok das heißt wenn ich das für den editor
umrechnen muss dann muss ich punkte zurück in millimeter meine güte ok was haben die
sonst ok also das ist paper dimensions paper dimensions page size ist doch genau das gleich
oder page region imageable area das ist falsch das stimmt überhaupt dass das imageable area
ist das ist das ist das ist gelogen man muss da was man muss das ist immer das gleiche
die haben einfach müll angegeben teste mal mit der richtigen page size machen wir gleich
machen wir machen wir leute machen wir testen es jetzt mal mit der richtigen page size was
da rauskommt moment page size ist allen ernstes page size ist allen ernstes 102 152,1 alles
klar ok dann drucken wir das erste label noch mal label png page size page size gleich
was war das irgendwie kauten ok schauen wir mal jetzt hat das hochkant gedruckt jetzt
muss ich wahrscheinlich kippen vorher jetzt muss ich es vorher kippen jetzt jetzt muss
ich jetzt muss ich ok ich trau mich nicht ich trau mich nicht das noch mal zu machen
minus o landscape trau ich mich das jetzt noch mal oder nicht landscape what the fuck
alter
wartet mal kurz wir müssen mal ein leeres was druckt der da jetzt überhaupt
der hat da sonst was gedruckt chat
messes schiebe reflektion online monka ist da ist er hier ok also das mit landscape wir
müssen das wir müssen leute wir müssen das rumdrehen wir müssen das wir müssen das wir
müssen das rumdrehen also home hi wobei ich ich drehe das hier rum ssh fs moment image
magic rotate 90 grad weiß nicht wie das funktioniert also rotate image convert input rotate 90
grad alles klar das brauche input label rotate out ist label 90 punkt npg png mann er zu lang
gebraucht um das zu rotieren chrome label 90
ok hat funktioniert mal massive cpu intensiv anscheinend so ein kleines label zu rotieren
ok also label 90 was
ich check es nicht mehr was macht er denn da
das sieht doch relativ gut aus jetzt ok leute wir müssen es einfach aus irgendwelchen gründen
rotate und dann sieht es gut aus guck mal einfach richtig rotate und dann sieht es gut
aus wisst ihr was scheiß drauf hier einfach 180 grad rotieren krupps ist nicht in der
lage es ordentlich selbst zu rotieren wir müssen es einfach rotieren und dann können
wir bei 89 mal sonst was bleiben wobei oben oben fehlt auch ein stückchen guckt mal ein
stückchen ist da schon aber who cares mir doch egal ist schon ok ist schon in ordnung
kannst du vielleicht einfach wird und ich mache gar nichts mehr bei der page size ich
mache gar nichts mehr das ist ein label writer 450 ok sehr schön aber das das funktioniert
prinzipiell so jetzt ist wahrscheinlich die rolle halb leer oder nah nee ein paar sind
noch drauf guck mal was wir alles für n müll gedrückt haben
ich brauche auf jeden fall noch ein paar kleinere etiketten davon dann aber das finde ich also
leute da muss ich sagen das ist doch echt in ordnung da kann man sich nicht beschweren
das ist ok kannst du die jetzt doppelt bedrucken rückseite oder was nie auf der rückseite
geht nicht ich kann die doppelt bedrucken indem ich die einfach mehrfach rein mache
ja aber dann hast du halt so dinger hier nee nee da merkt sich nicht du kannst ich kann
die doppelt doppelt reinschieben doppelt rein stecken gatschi bass kein problem funst
nee farbe geht nicht farbe farbe geht nicht so aber das ist schon mal gut zu wissen das
ist gut zu wissen weil jetzt weiß ich wie ich den wie ich den krempel hier aufrufen
muss und jetzt kann ich das machen wir aber heute nicht sage ich gleich dazu jetzt kann
ich mir also was ich vorhabe ist eigentlich warum ich das ausprobiert habe ist folgendes
die offizielle app für ios ist kacke ich weiß gar nicht ob es play store ob es den
play store überhaupt was gibt ok die play store bewertung ist genauso beschissen also
die haben sich das wohl rechtlich verdient dass ihre mobile app wohl cross platform scheiße
ist so was ich mir gedacht habe was man machen könnte ist folgendes kennt ihr draw iow wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich kennt ihr trough wobei das ja nicht mehr trough heißt das heißt die
jetzt die krams punkt nett so was ich mir gedacht habe ist mir könnten eine web anwendung
machen wo wir trough im bed das ist kein das darf man das ist das das wollen die auch und
dann könnte man hier drin seine labels design die labels werden einfach als png abgespeichert
und vom backend an den label drucker geschickt das heißt man hätte was wo man ohne drucker
treiber ohne irgendwelche zusatzsoftware einfach nur im browser das aufmachen muss label design
und und drucken kann und das auch mit mobile ich meine trough iow funktioniert auf mobile
jetzt sagen wir mal so naja äh wo stellt man den kram hier nochmal um leute ich hab's vergessen
wo ist das nochmal da ne hier auf mobile ansicht ja das aber es funktioniert bestimmt besser
mobile als den ihre komische app ich glaube ich muss f5 drücken vorher das funktioniert
sonst nicht ja guck jetzt hat das auch erkannt ja so würde das so würde das jetzt auf auf
mobile aussehen also das kann man das kann man denke ich durchaus verwenden kennt jemand
chat meine frage und kennt ihr eine alternative zu trough iow als javascript library also
also quasi einen diagramm editor oder was heißt diagramm so den visio so ein online
visio library so was wie trough iow oder diagrams diagrams app diagrams wie auch immer kennt ihr
noch eine alternative dazu weil die haben ihren source code komplett auf github mermaids
js ne das war doch ascii zu ascii zu kram oder ne ne ne ich ich mein wirklich was wo
man malen kann wie in visio ne ne wie gesagt ich mein sowas hier wirklich sowas hier wo
man malen kann und sachen rumschieben und so und icons einfügen und und sagen switch
und in switch rein track und droppen und sowas ich glaube da ist trough ja auch ziemlich
einzigartig aber überlegt doch mal das wäre ziemlich cool oder wir machen eine web anwendung
für für wo wir trough iow embedden dann kann man kann man ein label speichern und
dann per png im hintergrund an den label printer schicken der trough champ genau also ich habe
trough iow noch nie embedded aber das geht das schreiben die explizit dass das das dafür
gedacht ist so und dann machen wir eine ganz simple seite da kannst du einfach alte labels
laden und neue neue labels anlegen und dann geht halt ein trough iow auf müssen wir halt
nur gucken ob man trough iow irgendwie konfigurieren kann mit den standardkursen ja also hier page
setup kann man sagen page custom inches jetzt fangen die auch mit diesem shit an inches
jetzt gehts wieder los ok jetzt muss ich den kram in inches umrechnen kann man kann man
export spng ich hoffe der macht dann 300 dpi oder so include a copy of my diagram ok das
kann man auch embedden lassen alles klar ja da machen wir irgendwie super simple web anwendung
kannst du ein neues etikett anlegen dann geht dein editor auf kannst speichern kannst ausdrucken
oder kannst alte laden und neu ausdrucken das wäre doch easy dass sowas bauen wir und
dann kann man drücken und hat einen super editor ohne dass man irgendwelchen dymoshit
braucht und man muss ja auch mal sagen qualitativ ist das wirklich echt in echt in ordnung
ich mein es ist ja keine es hat halt keine farbe aber wer braucht schon farbe man für
etikett für etiketten geht das doch durch geht das doch komplett in ordnung so spooky
musik ja aber wie gesagt die web anwendung machen wir heute nicht ist mir zu anstrengend
jetzt noch was natürlich auch noch eine möglichkeit wäre ist gar kein png zu drucken sondern
direkt über kups direkt über kups per ip p könnte man drucken kups kups ip p da habe
ich aber noch habe ich aber noch nie gemacht was willst du die maschine oder kabel beschriften
beschränke beschriften schubladen beschriften ab und zu mal etikett für briefe drucken
hat jemand ip p schon mal irgendwie verwendet gibt es da npm packages für euer gibt es
anscheinend gibt es da gibt es da net packages das ist überhaupt ip p kups ja ip p heißt
krempel internet printing protokoll for no chairs ok wie macht man das pdf ne ip p ist
jetzt moment läuft mein kups jetzt netz das minus 631 kups ja aber nur auf localhost
ne auch überall alles klar mein kups und kups brau braus brauset ob wir das mal schnell
ausprobieren ob der krempel funktioniert ob wir das per ip p an kups schicken könnte
ok mal gucken was was was passiert dann eigentlich wenn ich hier hingehe hat ttp haben wir ja
karl ja das da nicht hier localhost not found er ist auch nicht printer das ist ja auch
jumo oder so ok das weiß ich nicht wie man das den kups einrichtet aber aber da läuft
schon mal da läuft schon mal irgendein webservice drauf das finde ich schon mal super 12168
was haben wir für eine ip was 13631 ok über ein browser geht das schon mal nicht auf warum
nicht karl ahja das ist nicht von außen erreichbar guck mal das ist nur das ist nur localhost
erreichbar wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt trick 17 leute ab install firefox was ja ok
wir machen jetzt x forwarding vom raspberry pi da muss ich nix weil ich könnte auch den
port weiterleiten egal installieren firefox wer das noch nicht gesehen hat das ist sehr
praktisch manchmal nicht für tägliche sachen aber manchmal wenn man einen rechner hat der
irgendwo hinkommt aber man selbst nicht und man braucht einen browser kann man sich dort
einen browser installieren und kann sich dann die grafikausgabe lokal weiterleiten lassen
wenn er da mal fertig installiert hat der installiert natürlich alle möglichen grafiklibraries
und sonst was zum glück hat der raspberry pi eine ssd sonst wäre das richtig langsam
aber was da alles installiert für lull hd 4k chat meine frage an euch weeps in oder weeps
out firefox so und jetzt haben wir den browser vom raspberry pi aus was sollten wir haben
irgendwann demnächst drei drei tage später aus irgendwelchen gründen darf ich keinen
firefox aufmachen vom raspberry das ist neu das geht normalerweise und die ssh verbindung
ist auch weg weiß gg eats warum das geht nicht mit x keine ahnung warum das nicht funktioniert
wegen meinem lokalen oder was weiß ich ach komm scheiße chrome egal ich will jetzt dass
das funktioniert firefox ist zu 6 hat der checkt dass ob lokal schon was läuft ist auch
ein firefox ist kein chrome firefox oder ja baut firefox macht port form durch mache
jetzt browser forwarding x forwarding beste die richtig coole geschichte ist sox proxy
über ssh und dann lokal den browser auf dem ssh proxy umstellen das ist richtig hrq dann
da sind wir doch da haben wir doch unseren chrome der läuft jetzt auf raspberry pi deswegen
resize da auch so langsam man sieht ja auch schon wie sie leckt so lokal host 631 kups
da sind wir und das ist nicht lokal host bei mir lokal host lokal host auf raspberry pi
was kann man da jetzt schönes machen using network printers habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
die pp will ich haben aha monka es was für ein ding soll ich machen
was was ist denn das für eine nicht ssh fs was ist denn das für eine ura kurk also lokal
host 631 printers name name ist dymo printer das scheint zu funktionieren oder funktioniert
es wirklich dymo printer jobs scheiße das wird tatsächlich funktionieren und da drüber
kann ich dann trocken oder ich habe das doch ich habe das noch nie gemacht ich habe keine
ahnung ob das funktioniert das das test das testen wir jetzt mal also wie geht das ok
ich muss jetzt leute irgendwelche note js experts hier
das ist mir glaube ich jetzt zu so wie er die pp png karl kann man das mit karl machen
print kups kann ich dem kann ich kups direkt übers netzwerk ein png schicken wahrscheinlich
nicht also ich will ich will sowas machen aber ich will ich will kein pdf machen sondern
ne das ist mir zu high iq was what the fuck ne das das ist mir das ist mir zu high iq
das wäre natürlich das wäre natürlich super nice wenn das funktionieren würde weil dann
könnte ich kups wirklich alles machen lassen da müsste ich noch nicht mal komando zeilen
tools zusammenbauen da müsste ich nicht mal pngs machen in dem sinn und auf dem server
speichern sondern ich müsste einfach entweder als pdf exportieren oder als png und dann
per ip p direkt an den drucker schicken was ab search ip p was was kommt was kommt dann
raus nix wirklich brauchbares na ich meine könnte das von windows aus mal ausprobieren
windows was wenn wir können window an den moment ich kann es unter widows nicht ausprobieren
weil ich den kram nicht freigegeben aber ich kenne mich mit kups nicht aus ich war ich
weiß nicht wie man mit kups ports freigibt etc kups kups kups de konf vielleicht aha
only listen for connections from kups listen muss man 000 eingeben oder sternchen ich meine
wir können ausprobieren was ist das eigentlich für eine dumme standard konfig mit maus an
system ctl restart restart kups kups de netz das und jetzt lauscht das an 631 ok das heißt
ich kann jetzt das hier aufmachen mit der ip von rechner 121 27 nein 127 verbinden lul
weh wenn so einfach ist es nicht so einfach ist es noch nicht das das wäre zu zu easy
so jetzt muss ich irgendwelche listen allow oder sowas restrict access to server kann
ich aus dem letzten jahr 1000 man der a4 trocken ist bei dem ding schon mal nix der strict access
to server oder ok kups allow deny wie geht das shit ok enable ja zeig her location allow
ja das da ist ja abfakt wer hat sich das denn wieder ausgedacht man ok restart was
fehlt ane so und jetzt und jetzt darf ich darf ich jetzt please verbinden immer noch warum
waren diese abfakt konfig immer das können die sich nehmen was besseres ausdenken als
was 1985 aktuell war
vor admin access keine ahnung das stimmt ja gar nicht das stimmt ja gar nicht leute
ist es ist es so oder ist es ist es so ich habe missgemacht stimmt gar nicht meine ip
ich meine ich kann ich kann auch einfach zwei reinschreiben schon funktioniert kaum macht
man es richtig dann kups ctl remote any jetzt wird es aber hi iq aber es scheint ja zu
funktionieren so und windows epp printer wie wie macht man das habe ich noch nie gemacht
drücker printer printer und scanner ok printer moment da den demo gefunden einfach so na gut
wahrscheinlich weil sie im gleichen gleichen netzwerk ist add device connecting funktioniert
schon mal das wäre zu easy gewesen zu easy wenn es einfach funktionieren würde so einfach
kann das nicht sein dass es einfach enden kann nee nee nee nee guck mal jetzt ist es
abgekackt jetzt macht er gar nichts mehr
ready hat man vielleicht auch irgendwelche settings oder so was manage hardware properties
epp class driver print nein nein nein nein nein nein nein ich printe definitiv keine
testpage dann ist mein dann ist mein band leer aber was wir probieren können ist rent
demo guck mal der erkennt sogar ob hochkant oder ob das jetzt funktioniert portrait landscape
fit fit to print scale shrink to printable was aber lieber so fit fit to printable was
ist denn das rote was ist denn das rote aber das geld ist viel zu klein aber woher weiß
der vor allem woran ich drucken kann guck mal hier hrq ding fit fit to printable moment
es ist ja schwachsinn ha leute das ist ja müll was wir hier gemacht haben document setup
wir haben sie hier noch das andere eingestellt 89 mal 36 war es ne ja besser print achso hier
paper size jeder stimmt ja gar nicht die feind bei driver 58 mal 101 nicht nicht wirklich
nicht so ganz du musst dem cups noch die auflösung angeben ja wahrscheinlich aber wie ist kein
printer da doch was was willst du von mir das ist auch bedienbar aus dem letzten jahrtausend
mann boah keine ahnung ach hier die falls media custom achja ok das muss man wohl standardmäßig
umstellen der hat irgendwie 58 mal sonst was drinne dabei müsste er aber das kann man
auch überschreiben hier guck mal media size was war meins 32 3252 moment du mal 39 mal
36 mal 89 wie hießen die dinger 99012 99012 large address ja was habe ich denn da für
ein passport keine ahnung das ist es mein password anscheinend ich habe kein kopf kopf
das zeug angegeben aber ich kann das ich kann es doch eigentlich hier überschreiben
36 36 zu 89 soll nur mal kurz gucken was da rauskommt cups no remote admin alles klar
der kennt ja chill free kennt sich aus krasser cups admin am start ok restart cups cups please
dabei ist mein raspberry pi wieder abgekackt was ist denn mit dem raspberry pi los mann
warum ist er denn jetzt abgeschissen stimmt da was mit der ssd oder so das ist auf jeden
fall nicht normal aber da ist er wieder abtime abtime eine minute oder was hier jetzt was
ist das für eine komische abtime anzeige oder ist er eine minute ab ne ach eine stunde
das ist einfach nur so glatt die zeit jetzt wegen jetzt ergibt das den ich sage das ergibt
aber doch es ist einfach zufälligerweise so glatt gewesen so ist das wieder da restart
aus irgendwelchen gründen ist es jetzt wieder nicht erreichbar alles klar was sollte ich
vorher eingeben no remote admin oder sowas cups ich mache jetzt einfach mal was der was
der was der chat sagt was remote remote any ok chill free cut plan wir machen das jetzt
einfach geht nicht jebaited ane ich habe das doppelt kopiert restart cups system ctl restart
cups was auch immer ich da gerade mache ich habe kein blassen schimmer das ist ziemlich
ziemlich brutal für cups hier neu zu starten wie es gerade aussieht high cpu ok manage
printers demo set default options 902 large address set default ja meine güde ey was
ein pepega kram large address jetzt aber ok pie raspberry verbinden no god no god please
no no no leck mich ne das war ich jetzt nett kein bock ich drücke das jetzt auch nicht
aus wer weiß was ich weiß was der mir da wieder was der mir da wieder raushaut ich
wollte nur prinzipiell gucken ob der kram per ipv verfügbar ist weil wenn das verfügbar
ist also sprich wenn ich jetzt einen drucker habe dann heißt das ich muss kann mir diesen
ich kann mir den png kram sparen ich kann direkt per ipv auf cups drucken das ist in
sofern gut weil ansonsten müsste ich hier sowas hier machen müsste ich halt so diese
hier müsste ich mir selbst auf der server seite png sachen zusammen wurschten ich will
es defaultmäßig gar nicht umstellen das ist unsinnig ich muss das eh überschreiben
beim beim drucken dann ok nice aber das das gefällt mir schon mal also es funktioniert
ja prinzipiell wir haben schon ausgedruckt und es tut kann man das wieder löschen wie
löschen wir den kram denn jetzt remove weil sonst backt mein windows wahrscheinlich gleich
wieder rum da muss ich mal gucken wie man aber per ipv was drucken kann soll mir soll mir
soll mir recht sein weil da können wir wirklich so eine mini web anwendung bauen mit true
in drinnen ja alles klar leute hat ja gut funktioniert wir sehen uns im nächsten stream
ich hau ab da ist für heute bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut